I love this duo this is a great seat for
me oh yeah right
I just want to see if Miller was gonna
dance it off there was a slate head Bob
and then he saw me look and said no more
dance Oh Marty no more mr. serious this
week
apparently it's draft week boys and gals
and ladies and gents left go show what's
good the men from stick to football are
joining me Matt Miller Connor Rogers
they're hosting an event tonight very
excited to see that happening we're
recording this one Tuesday we're putting
this out on a Wednesday the main reason
is the draft is Thursday and I want you
guys to be able to listen to this and
enjoy it and have some time to process
it and have a day or two so we're
changing up the release schedule hope
you guys enjoyed Isaac Nauta and my man
Quincy Williams I was in Atlanta I got
to interview my body double algae
Crumpler I got to interview Pro Bowler
Kevin by yard from the Titans and Nick
I'm gonna print this music down really
quick thank you and Austin Hooper who's
the [ __ ] man
yeah he's the man so all those will be
happening later but it's all draft right
now before we get to the draft two
things I want to get to today Frank
Clark traded from Seattle to Kansas City
Kansas City gives up a first-round pick
this year a second-round pick next year
and they swap thirds and then
immediately Frank Clark gets a 105
million dollar deal with a 63 million
dollar signing bonus or guaranteed
whatever it is what was your initial
reactions
I was excited as a new member of the
Chiefs Kingdom I was very excited for
that no I I think Frank Clark is one of
the five or six best edges in the NFL so
this makes sense
the Seahawks didn't appreciate him they
didn't then we're gonna pay him he
tweeted that they lied to him when they
gave Russell Wilson the money so I like
this and and I I think this is a classic
case of team's overvaluing draft picks
because like I said to you guys when
this tray got announced you're not gonna
find a pass rusher at 29 that can do for
you a Frank Clark camp there's no way in
an immediate
window that Frank Clark right or is
windows right now I don't even think
there's a player in this client like
maybe Nick bow so there's no player in
this class that's on the level of Frank
Clark really hey Frank Clark's him he's
amazing and I know like five there's the
all field stuff you got to talk about it
you got to factor it in but you know
he's been in the NFL for four years and
hasn't had any problems I think you said
this on the last time you were on the
honor that you thought Frank Clark maybe
going to the chief yeah the chief oh
thank you love go the Chiefs are always
you know the kind of the match made in
heaven here you see the return
see I don't wanted more pics they had
four picks head in this draft they get a
lot of people were skeptical I believe
when Adam Schefter tweeted out they were
gonna hold firm for a first-round pick
they get the first-round pick they get a
second-round pick and then the swap of
third-round picks so yeah when you look
at this now they're 21 and 29 in the
first round which is very interesting
ammo to play with there Frank Clark is
an every down player I think this is an
upgrade from d4 table viously a better
scheme fit for the new scheme they'll be
running he's a great run defender he's
coming off a 13 sack season he's 25
years old it's a lot of money and of
course the off fields the Chiefs are
gonna get hammered a lot because they
are now the franchise that takes on the
guys with the best of violence issues
yes without a doubt there's no way
around it Tyree cool Seattle who is
still looking to retool here they have
Russell Wilson for the future
quarterback you can win with for a very
long time now they have the mo for a
team that I think will draft very well
I'm excited to see what they do with
these picks all the mocks that I've
looked at all the podcast I've listened
to everyone says it's a very deep pass
rusher draft but they always say after
about the sixth guy it falls off a cliff
yeah and the way that I've been hearing
all these mocks going six is going in
that 1920-21 right around that Seattle
pick yes
Kansas City probably wasn't gonna get
this guy and they needed a pass rusher
with Steve spagnolo defense they got a
pretty good depth right now on that deal
I can you hear yourself no I can't I
think we're gonna need to get you a
thing so if we'll see if Nick come in
here we'll see he's gonna come in here
so everyone gets to see Nick for the
first time which is incredible
something's just broken I was putting it
helmet on he's gonna come in but I look
at Kansas City you have
um Wow and see this just came on the
bleacher report up Geron read out four
to six weeks with the sports hernia yeah
he had surgery today
so the Seattle D line is taking a lot of
hits but back to the cheese Chris Jones
now you have Emmanuel Agua you have
Frank Clark you have the two draft picks
from last Jerry Lynn speaks last year
you have tanto pass neon it was second I
picked year before Derek naughty will
play the one technique a lot but you
have in my opinion Chris Jones and Frank
Clark is one of the best one-two punches
in the in all of the NFL right now Chris
Jones was one of the top three sackers
in football last year Frank Clark I've
laid out at 13 on his right so now both
of them had more sacks in the Raiders
and team by the way you still have the
most explosive offense in the NFL right
and all they really was it was a Miller
yeah so I think it's I think it's a lot
of money the amount of money kind of
scared me I think our studio fell apart
can you hear now
yeah thanks Miller's here for a [ __ ]
day and just breaks all this [ __ ] yes
incredible [ __ ] this would never
happen in the job [ __ ] house but I
think the money was a lot of money but I
also understand as a 25 year old pass
rusher he's good I don't worry about my
money a we stick to football salary caps
fake and it is especially with how much
it goes up right it's just gonna go up
so who cares I think if you you have a
window with mahomes there for a couple
more years under a team kindly deal you
have to strike you have to try look with
the Rams did last year you bring in
Marcus Peters to keep to leave and Tom
McCann sue bringing all these dudes and
you make a really good run yeah pretty
close I think the Chiefs are bred
features the most aggressive general
manager in the NFL and honestly that was
my big takeaway is I felt that trade was
great for the Chiefs it was bad for the
draft because the Chiefs are the team
that I thought might sneak up in there
at like a switch with the Bengals at 11
or some like the bills and maybe who
knows who they're going after you know
what I mean they would have gone after a
pastor that's what I'm saying the cool
thing is the chief still have two
second-round picks this year right and
now they have an earlier picking around
three they switched with Seattle so
thank you so they can still get a corner
they could still get a center and you
tossed off your biggest
need with a top-five player at that
position right I'm not just saying this
as a Missouri guy like this everyone's
gonna talk about OSC I don't want this
trade they have picks what percent of
first-round picks hit you don't need to
talk to me about overvaluing picks oh
it's amazing
yes we assume that they're gonna be
something like we talk about all the
pass rushers in this tract
guess what name name them for me sure
let's do it Nik Bosa
Jalen Brian burns clean and Ferro Montes
where Shawn Geary okay like four of them
have insane question marks about whether
or not they could ever even reach a
level of three of them have major injury
question right so that's what I'm saying
like oh but they could have had one of
those guys would have been a player the
window starts yeah I'm with you all the
way on this you get a 25 year old proven
player yeah that's an every down player
that is an ascending play yes do you
know who the last five people drafted
29th overall were ooh
Haven Brian Jaguars David a joke we all
like Dave and Brian okay David and joke
ooh Robert came DJ okay like Dorsett is
Dominique Easley yeah we go back farther
score Tyrell Patterson Harrison Smith
Gabe creamy it's always good to look at
that Kyle Wilson and Kim Nicks see all
about me when you hear a Hall of Famer
the only other story that I really want
to talk to before we go full-on draft is
the continued emergence of Russell
Wilson good lord
and I'm loving every minute of it and I
just wanted to say that Russell you're
braiding video was phenomenal I'm so
happy that this is not just a flash in
the pan that this is not a one-time
thing I a Ciara god bless you and to
everyone out there going the Seahawks
are gonna win the Super Bowl
I just think back to all the stories
that Richard Sherman and all those guys
were pretty much alluding to that
Russell Wilson was too corny to lead
them all those years and now he's like
the coolest dude ever and I love him
he's sitting on the Iron Throne man he's
the last one standing those dudes are
all gone now all gone and he's left
holding the bag and he's the clothes
look a lot of pressure
ya know world Thomas right I mean
legends out the door at this point yeah
so every cell might be the guy to do it
the guy to persevere now listen him yeah
he gonna do the NFL Draft strap your
voice
oh yeah there's a lot to unpack there
man
oh I'm happy for him though whatever you
got to do look all I want in this world
is for everyone to live their truth yeah
and if you're happy let's go for you but
can you imagine if oh man he just comes
out there and he's got like like a
do-rag coming out the back yeah oh he's
slowing Road up I would love yeah I'll
be get some tattoos I mean that's what's
next
that would help I'll give him a leather
jacket right here the lips yeah all
right I'll give Russell advice on
leather jackets you give them advice on
tattoos oh yeah and Connor's got the
hair taken yeah well get the hair done
NFL Draft week we're recording this on
Tuesday are there any little news or
nuggets or rumors that are buzzing in
your ears right now that we need to kind
of talk about I think this is the the
week where you try to just go back to
what you've been hearing since January
and block out what you're hearing most
recently so you know there have been
things like hope maybe the Raiders want
Dwayne Haskins that's why they sent
their scouts home I know they have a
super seat right so I don't believe that
I don't know I don't I don't believe it
especially because it just it's not you
know I know like we all get told things
and it's our responsibility to vet the
information to put it out there and I
understand that people might think that
will happen I just don't think it will
so I think with with smoke screens and
lying season it comes back to
relationships it's what we talk about a
lot on stick to football is that you
know trying to figure out who you can
trust and who you can't trust I've been
burned before badly
the Raiders send people home because
they don't trust anyone those guys
aren't coming back
that's my question everyone's making it
seem like they're bad guys should they
be trusting these people or was this a
move we just get hired as a general
manager like mike Mayock got hired
before
season so he has to exist for one whole
football season with Reggie McKinsey
Scouts right so it would be like but do
those scouts think that they have a
chance do you have such a good job that
they might keep their job yes yeah but
it's rare the Raiders have hit on some
pics yeah
the scouts don't make the picks okay
Reggie McKenzie yeah I know but that's
from my perspective I don't know if
somebody's sitting there going Khalil
Mack is the guy that's not how it works
I mean Scouts are basically like private
detectives they go out to gather
information they present the information
and they did this the Raiders did this
scouts presenting the information but
when it's time to stack the board that's
the advantage when they're protecting
yeah you're protecting people I think
that every team has this big [ __ ]
conference room they do you know why cuz
the [ __ ] Cowboys do it but they could
call it the Cowboys are very protective
about who can see that room yeah but
then they put it on national television
well after the fact yeah but like the
Colts even the Colts don't let some of
their top executives in that room right
they have the Patriots don't let anybody
in the Jets there's it has doors that
lock yes same thing as the Patriots like
then wire this sounds like a story that
normal people are like upset by but it's
not upsetting in the NFL where it's
uncommon to send your scouts home and
tell them don't come back it's common to
send them home and say we've had team
meetings we want to take a break come
back for the draft what's most uncommon
is the hey by the way don't come back
because you need those guys to call
undrafted free agents you might need
them a step in the room and that's the
part that I've been hearing it's they're
the ones that make the connections with
undrafted free agent source and they're
the ones that make the phone call and if
you don't think undrafted free agents
are important you're crazy
yeah because you go talk to Phillip
Lindsey and get that figured out real
quick like what's your take on this
whole you have a board set someone can
call them it wasn't right overwhelmingly
surprising besides the fact that listen
if you want to send them home for Easter
and say hey we're not gonna need you in
the draft room that's fine but to
Miller's point of just not working I
don't really understand that I do think
you DFAS matter I do think day three
guys those Scouts have a voice in the
room I mean the high-level executives
along with ownership are gonna sign off
on the top pick right and then you get
into the second third round and it might
be some of the
but rounds four till the UDF a period
those Scouts really do matter and they
will go to bat for their their guys and
I think some of the good scouting
departments give those guys a voice in
them and that's an important point
different teams do this differently so
it's not fair to say every NFL team does
this you know in Kansas City it's more
of a conversation you know in
Indianapolis on day three it might be
more of a conversation there are other
places where it's like a dictatorship
Bela Chan for the highway Mayock might
be wanting to come in and say listen I
was on TV no one really took me
seriously I'm going to control this
process and show you I know what I'm
doing I'm giving Mayock the benefit of
the doubt because every year we applaud
him for knowing all these guys right
like he got him and kuiper and you have
this ability to you have that rolodex
so really they've been he is well-versed
in all these guys like I don't think hey
I just came from nowhere like he was
probably like getting right he probably
did a 20-19 mock right after the 2018
you know what I mean like he knows these
guys I think it's very different and
I'll say this this is my ninth draft
basically doing the same job as him
right there's no way I could go be a
general manager right now there's a
difference between studying players and
knowing their traits and being able to
properly value them against your
existing roster like if I if a team
called me tomorrow I think that I get if
I gave you a team and you only had to
think about that team and you took all
that time that you spent on 32 teams and
32 combinations and all their needs and
all the time that you spent on looking
at their rosters and their changes and
it was on one not because I still think
even after even the Badger suit even
that and even the best general managers
don't hit 50% of course so then where's
the pressure there's well that's what I
think for me too I produced something
I've been open about the hardest part
for me would be building a scouting
department that would be the hardest
part for me I think I can evaluate what
talent I would need for the coaches and
work with the coaches to fill that in to
scheme I've been building the right
scouting department across the country
for an outsider of the league would be a
big challenge I think so trusting people
oh I'm just playing devil's that it's a
grip I love the question yeah because I
don't think it's there's an easy answer
right
what other
what about the whole Pete Prisco story
that the Cardinals aren't theirs tickets
Adam that's what he said okay doesn't
add up to me with them not I'm directly
calling someone out but not intending to
yeah what doesn't make sense to me is
that it was sold as ownership was
pushing for them to make that pick
Kliff Kingsbury right is pushing for
them to make that pick and that's why I
think that will be the pick I mean the
stories have been going back for months
that Kingsbury's been walking around
being like I want color I want color
yeah can I tell you my truth I am NOT
rooting against Kyler but I am rooting
for Josh Rosen to have a better career
than Kyler Murray and I'd like to I'd
like to explain why because what has
happened right now is this man as being
thrown in the trash I'm not saying
anyone's better I'm just saying because
of everything that's happened I'm
finding myself hoping that Josh Rosen
has a better career than calimary I
don't need either them to be a bust
if Josh Rosen wins three Super Bowls I
just hope Kyler wins too and the reason
is Josh Rosen has been under attack for
two years from his personality to a hot
tub picture to he cares about too much
other than football - he's a baby - like
he didn't do anything wrong the entire
season but yet we're bringing back those
narratives again that he must have been
an issue here's I let me just finish my
like this thing with it and so my thing
is the thing that will always stick out
to me about Rosen is his intelligence
and there was another quarterback that
had an attitude problem that's been very
intelligent that got [ __ ] over in the
beginning of his career and that's Aaron
Rodgers I'm not saying Josh Rosen coming
Aaron Rodgers but what I'm saying is
when a very intelligent guy that may
have interests outside of football gets
insulted and besmirched like this do you
know the motivation this man's gonna
have right now do you know the energy
that he's gonna have if there was ever a
doubt that if Josh Rosen was gonna not
want to play football I
all of that is gone now because now if
he walks away it's Oh was it too tough
for you Joshy oh you couldn't handle
that Josh no now he wants to destroy
people so I think that's how you would
be I don't think Josh Rosen's wired that
way because wouldn't he have done that
last year when he was the fourth
quarterback drafted
isn't that your motivation to be like
you know what [ __ ] the Jets
didn't take me the Giants did get me but
let's say he does get traded and let's
say he goes to a place like Los Angeles
chargers the situation that he had like
when have you ever seen a first-year
head coach other than Jim Tomsula get
canned like that's 75% not eating and
light and a chance I don't think he
stood a chance but my thing is more of
even if he wasn't wired that way
I truly believe what's happening him to
him right now will help get him wired
that way I think that and I'm not a
psychologist it also makes people fold
I mean Blaine Gabbert would be a diamond
if pressure made diamond so you think
Josh is I think I think there's
something to the fact when everyone says
hey this guy's not mentally tough or
even like teams that interviewed him
last year
I mean this was a player who basically
said if I'm not in New York I don't want
to play and so the the Jets and Giants
neither of them took him he goes to
Arizona and you know what it wasn't a
great situation but you know what else
wasn't a good situation the Buffalo
Bills with Josh Allen Sam Darnell in the
Jets not really a great situation either
hey I think it's not fair to compare
those two to his really I know that's of
line alone abysmal yeah but some of that
is also on him and if there will him
like what I was going to say is we're
not in that locker room and is a a
player who there have been reports about
right well I think if a new coach wants
to come in there and make a change that
it's necessarily a reflection on how he
was in locker room
you're just enforcing my pour more than
I'm rooting for Josh frozen hard as [ __ ]
I liked Josh Rosen I want to see him
succeed I just think I mean it's this is
kind of like Corey Coleman like oh
everybody loved Corey Coleman okay well
at some point you don't stick with your
first team you go to a second team they
you have to eventually have that fire in
you to I'm gonna prove everyone wrong
and I don't know if Rosen has that fight
oh I mean we should like vetted dinner
on this or something okay well
Connor already owes I don't know if kind
of rose me we made it I've been trying
to figure that out because I don't I
truly don't know
yeah me and Connor made a bet before
they went golf to try EFT I said Wentz
will be the better quarterback he said
gone three years in three years an hour
now we're going to year four and like I
think I won and I think Connor thinks I
want to but I said oh I don't know I
think off to the better quarterback what
if you want a very neutral observer I
had them one too I like both of them a
lot I think it's very hard to judge
right now because of wences injury
scoffs a nothing rookie season yeah I
don't let's ever thrown interceptions if
I could if I had if you were handing me
a team and say take one of these two
quarterbacks I'd rather have golf but I
would say though that I really think
it's fair to say that right now it's
still split and they're and they're
reaching their one year extension which
is nuts it's unbelievable but four years
in you can make arguments for both sides
I will gladly get you the jersey no I
just want to make sure no I I'm willing
to ride this out I got enjoying it too
yeah yeah so we're gonna do but I
thought we thought three years oh that's
plenty yeah yeah no we did well it
didn't look really good after your one
for me we are going to be doing the
draft Thursday Friday you guys are
taking over fully on Saturday Thursday
join us at 7:50 it's gonna be live on
Twitter YouTube and the BR app we are
going live the entire time all four or
five hours we are not taking any
commercial breaks
we have tweaked the system a little bit
where we're still gonna be making videos
but we've streamlined it so that we have
more time to actually talk between the
picks and I do have some questions for
you guys that I want to talk about and
my first one is it's the Peter teal
question Peter teal ask a question
apparently at every interview and every
dinner party which is what is one thing
that you believe that no one else
believes I think it's a very good
question so I'm gonna go to Connor first
oh the pressures on what is one thing
about this draft that you believe that
you're not hearing anyone else say wow
like player wise anything anything
anything okay I don't think Josh Allen
is
double-digit sack player ever I mean Vic
Beasley walked into 12 okay so that's
why I'm scared to do yes he's not
consistently yes he's a good player and
does a lot of other things very well yes
but he's not like the Nick Bose level
Bradley Chubb a year ago kind of pass
rusher I might have one to add after
Miller goes this is a such an open
question and we hear so many different
pinions it's a fine one where I'm like
I'm really unique on this at this point
okay no think about I and I'll say
before I give mine you and I were
talking about this before we start
recording I don't consume a lot of draft
media cuz I feel like I'm an opinion
maker so I don't want to you want to be
swayed yeah and I like Connor put out a
big board i retweeted it I love Connor I
didn't read it because I don't want his
opinions to mess with mine sure about
you so I didn't look at it I will say
this I think tell me one of your
opinions I'll tell you if I hear it I
think Jeffrey Simmons is a top-five
player in this class that's a good one
like on my Hallett overall player
Jeffrey Simmons is a he's a stud I don't
know that the gap between Bosa and
Quinton and him would be that big if it
weren't for injuries and the video from
before he went to Mississippi State as a
San Francisco 49er fan former yeah as a
current I'm not lettin ya you guys had a
string where you drafted ACL injuries
and stuff like that right from
experiencing that and seeing what
happens where do you then take a guy
that's in your mind a tough I've talent
that could miss all of or just part I
think he still goes first round and
there is a lot of precedent for that
guys like Cedric oh boy he was an
offensive tackle came out still went
first round so I think Jeffrey Simmons
probably goes in the 15 to 19 range you
think he goes before top to number 20 I
think so yeah I definitely think so it
is concerning with the Niners I think
they also took guys they didn't really
love football like tank Carradine you
know it looks like a great player
Florida State got hurt never really came
back from it I think some of it is also
just you have to invest in the player
and their their hunger to rehab and like
you were saying rosin like how much fire
does this guy have to come back you know
that they also draft Marcus Lattimore
had no legs left right you can't really
put that on the player I was looking at
the draft and
I feel like if Simmons is there at 24 or
27 the Raiders in my mind are obligated
to take them because I believe that a
team that has multiple picks at that
point of the draft that one of them if
you could get the value of a possible
top 10 pick and you have that many I
feel like you have to I would bet you
you can tell me whatever you want I
don't even care
I'll bet you anything if he's on the
board at 19 the Titans take him really
yeah
well I do know that you know people
there so anything I'll bet ya not
betting on that way anything okay so
that so that's okay so there's a little
nugget yeah so you think if Jeffrey
Simmons there at 19 sit tight Wow and
they'll pair him up with Harold Landry
for the next four or five years yeah and
he'll play inside Landry plays outside
and then Verano they they want to get
bigger in Tennessee Upjohn and he helps
them do that so all right that's a good
one I'm gonna say in terms of my what do
I believe that no one else does I'm
gonna say that and I don't even know
this isn't this is just opinion I have
Buffalo's the most interesting part of
this draft to me because I believe at
10:00 with Denver 11 with Cincinnati 13
with Miami and 15 with Washington
that's the murderer row of a quarterback
ago right and I think that Buffalo in
every [ __ ] mock that I've seen is
taking heed Oliver at 9 yeah yeah I
don't think he'll be there and and and
he might not be there yeah but I don't
when I look at Buffalo and what they did
this offseason they made a shitload of
free agency moves yeah to the point
where they don't have really any glaring
need that they have to fix right now
they have veterans they have guys that
can make it work
I look at Buffalo as the catbird seat in
this draft at number 9 and I feel like
if one of these teams want to trade up
there and get their quarterback whether
it is Haskins or whoever ends up making
it there I think Buffalo is gonna be the
crazy part of this train and I think
Detroit will be because they already
letting people know like hey we won out
and it could be a cheap move so I think
the same idea that you just had
yeah seems do you want to get ahead of
people like Dannenberg teams want to get
ahead of sorry I just want to get ahead
of some other people so I think that's I
think Detroit at eight makes a lot of
sense Buffalo at nine would as well but
the bills
yeah they add a lot of players
especially the offensive line they
basically spot an offensive line so a
lot of times we've mocked Jonah Williams
they're right Oliver I think a name to
watch there's Christian Wilkins from
Clemson okay player that a lot of people
have higher than I do that's one that
I'm not having as some other people I
wouldn't be surprised if they went there
to try to give one thing they might lack
is interior pass rush right let me just
read off really quick what they did this
offseason just for everybody at the wide
receiver position Cole Beasley John
Brown so you get the slot guy and a
possible deep guy you get tightness Seki
from Washington there's a great
rotational player Spencer Long John
Feliciano Mitch Morse later Ian Waddell
and Quinton Spain those are all in the
offensive line at six guys they signed
in free just on the offensive line they
get two corners and Kevin Johnson DJ
Gaines I'm not saying they're the answer
I'm just saying they filled a lot of
their holes yeah they did and especially
the offensive line cuz that was the big
one with Josh Allen what I like about
Jonah at nine for them is that a lot of
people believe he's a five position
player where he could be an elite Center
or guard very good tackle I think that's
really important for them now I don't
know if he makes it there because I
think he's in play for the lines at
eight and I know Matt has said they've
made it clear they want to move out of
eight but when it comes down to it I
mean the Jets can't find a dance partner
for three what makes you think the lines
are fine I'm one of eight and so if that
was one of the questions that I sent to
you guys ahead of time which was
everyone loves to say during the draft
they want to trade down everyone we all
wanted to
who were the teams that you think want
to trade up no I think that is the
harder I think Washington is the team
that would like to move up at this point
okay their quarterback at 15 it's do the
Jets when we're back to 15 I think they
would if that's where you you feel like
you have to get in front of Oakland or
if you have to get fun of the Giants
yeah you would probably hop back to 15
and try to get a Brian burns yeah I
player so I think Washington is an
interesting team to watch I've heard the
Texans
they're Texans would come up for a
tackle they warrant that as we want
andre Dillard and now it's out there
that they want Andre Dillard right so
and I don't think Andre Dillard makes it
to them
really and they have to get to Shawn
Watson a tackle
yes come on man like they there's no
like oh we didn't fall to us home run
for your life again like no you got a
goatee it's done in the [ __ ] this thing
about Houston is they have two
second-round picks so they there as well
I'm curious if we're gonna see a
Patriots trade up that's what I was
going to say the Patriots have 12 paid
twelve picks and like five or six in the
tie in the first three rounds they have
all the ammunition to move up that's why
I was also saying oh maybe they send
like a three Natuna for Josh Rosen or
something like that yeah I would or they
have the uh no to get crazy for things
I'm actually by the way you know damn
well that if Josh Rosen went to the
Patriots you'd be scared shitless about
what you just said because you know that
they don't understand I don't know if he
has the mentality if he goes to New
England and Tom Brady's like hey dude
we're gonna make this work and I'm gonna
show you what I've had to do to be great
but he'll bear here's another thing he's
not a [ __ ] rookie anymore
like everyone's talked about Josh Rosen
like he needs to be taught the NFL he
just got thrown in the fire for an
entire she's but he learned the NFL is
he does but he you also learn a lot of
bad habits in that time so those are
gonna have to get fixed thank you
because you've played behind a shitty
offensive line she's got to learn how to
step up and schlock it which yeah but I
feel like people are acting like he's
gonna be like all right no nerves a team
meeting but all the places that we've
talked about him going are the Chargers
the Patriots he's thinking on the
[ __ ] field right away if I'm Josh I'm
going and let's say it's it's the
Chargers and we're back on Josh Rosen
chargers or the Patriots I mean you get
to watch one of the Hall of Famer woes
are the best sponsor and that's the
thing they're not gonna [ __ ] help you
and that's totally fine you don't need
to just watch them like just watch what
they do and emulate it you're around
them every day that's it
but if you go to Miami or Washington and
you got to play right away so I don't
think Miami's gonna draft a quarterback
this year I don't either
no I think they're on it for next year I
said wait they're doing the
Browns which is build up the o-line
build up the d-line get the rest of the
team really good and then bring in the
quarterback with the five year low
contractor yeah I think when you look at
Miami it just makes sense for them to
capitalize off that edge group you
talked about left go where after we run
out of those six they're in the range
where they can get one and Brian Flores
is going down there he knows what he
wants what he needs think Montes sweat I
know Madison medicals could cause him to
drop for a while I thought that was the
best scheme I didn't do personally now
it might be Brian burns yeah
Brian burns makes a lot of sense there
just knowing that they're the Patriots
south and we've talked earlier about how
the Patriots do not care about pass
rushers they seem a team like to me that
would rather get crash ends and just
really big physical guys because that's
what New England does yeah it's just
finding someone that fits that like
those guys who are the guys in this
year's draft and there's not there's not
one I mean not in the first round like
you could get Zach Allen in the second
or Charles a mini Hugh and the third
what there's not that I'll take all your
innocence like there's not a lot of
those high profile but that's why I'm
very interested in Dexter Lawrence
because Dexter Lawrence is the size guy
that I look at all these New England
teams all over the league right now and
they just want size and it just I I look
at Dexter law or the one I want Dexter
Lawrence to go to 28 I want him to go to
the Chargers badly that's because they
are so [ __ ] small that Dexter
Lawrence there would be green one of the
weird thing I said it on our Monday show
and I know it caught me off guard one of
the weird connections I've heard now
maybe the Giants would come back and for
him is that 17 don't rule out Dexter
Lawrence to the Giants which everyone
goes makes so much everyone goes that's
so early and it's like whoa I don't
think it's that it's not that early do
you know what they said who they said
that about last year Doron Payne high
impact defensive lineman I don't think
can go too early
I've always said that feet availeth well
what if the Giants yeah the Giants took
Haskins at 6 and Dexter Lawrence at 17
I'd be like that makes a lot of sense
yeah I'll be pretty Giants fans would be
pretty happy I'd rip that draft
personally I think 28 that's a fake
Haskins hater
yeah he's my number two quarterback I
like Haskins Sahra fake has
he says that he doesn't he like he'll
grade the Haskins picked poorly but
Haskins top-20 for you isn't he uh I
don't know
let me check probably some people Hank
that's like the best quarterback to come
out in years no see that's where I come
in
that's what I disagree with he's there's
no way he's not better than golfer went
I don't think he's better than the guys
last year I think he he's incredibly
smart and he he got so much better
throughout the course the season so one
year starter in the Big Ten that's just
hard for me to get excited about when
the guy doesn't have the biggest arm
he's not a great athlete he's just kind
of like you know it's just there what's
funny is today we were doing a draft
rehearsal again draft Thursday night 750
rate here bleacher report you to Twitter
and they put up
Haskins measurables and I felt really
done because I thought Haskins was 65
it's just the way he stands well the
Heisman to a Kyler Murray I know
hilarity look feel like out on the field
he looks taller than 6-3 he's a thick
dude yeah yeah carries they're all dumb
he carries 235 easily yeah your theñi
six five five or six five like 240 now
he's like 6-3 240 yeah he's the big kid
all right what has been your favorite
smoke screen of traff season thus far
Miller is ready to go no I don't know if
I am um I think the Broncos drew LA
quanis was pretty good for a while yeah
and I don't even know if that was maybe
real and they just backed off maybe when
they got a Flacco that's a good point
how do you how do you notice when a
smoke screen is a smoke screen okay
here's the perfect example and I don't
truly know this is an example of when
you're conflicted I've been told by a
lot of people that I trust on multiple
sides not just like Oh a scout or like
oh like a coach like multiple sides that
the Raiders do like Dwayne Haskins now
what also make senses the Raiders to get
out there that they liked Wayne Haskins
so somebody trades ahead of them to take
him and the Raiders get Quinn and
Williams not the Jets and you know who
it makes a lot of sense for that to
happen
it makes less sense for the Jets to put
that out there as well because they want
to trade out of three we're
they can't find a dance partner so what
do you do you say the Raiders like
Dwayne asked and someone comes up I mean
we see this every year we saw the mr.
Biscay draft right it was that Oh
Cleveland might actually trade back up
to number two of the Niners team so the
Bears had to trade up one spot to make
sure they got their guy I think this
happens often that you and I know that I
have been used before for this yeah what
I'll say is I think you've been used
this year oh I talked about this before
the whole draft season like recently
started do you think anyone tried to use
you or do you think you've been used at
all I definitely think so I don't know I
can't tell you why yet but like I'm sure
Friday night off yeah okay there'll be
something where you're like oh wow that
wasn't just that wasn't just true at all
I got used last year that I know of now
cuz we've had time there is a team and a
person told me hey our coaches are
really making a push for this guy so I
put it out there and it was true the
coaches work but they get going they
didn't pick based on what the coaches
wanted so it's like alright well I kind
of got used but that information wasn't
wrong and I think that's the hardest
part for us sometimes with fans because
fans when you tell them info that they
do not want to hear they say you don't
deserve your blue check or you're lying
or you're being used or this and that
but sometimes there are different
opinions in the building it doesn't mean
it was fake oh of course but I think all
don't realize that yeah like there are
coaches right now that do not like their
quarterbacks they're working with right
and they want to take another
quarterback that doesn't mean the GM or
the owner is gonna sign off on it right
very it's very tough so what what what
I've been some smoke screens that you've
enjoyed this season I think the the
Haskins golf or has been fun
what about even Haskins before Haskins
has been the smoke screen the whole time
he's falling out of favors he's flying
down the draft and I he's a lock at six
to the Jeff's favorite one that I like
it angered me and then I just started
laughing about it was the D K Metcalfe
would go top five we're even top ten
yeah like that was the one where there
was remember when he went to he was
going to for like a week after the Kop
yeah Darius I just saw your podcast tell
me how much Walker I'll tell you the one
that I
found it hard to believe and I know this
is probably the Connors the only one
that thinks this I don't think teams
like Daniel Jones as much as we've been
late on - let's talk about Daniel Jones
yeah because I have we never seen a
draft there are different parts of draft
Twitter and draft universe yeah there is
analytical and when it comes to
quarterbacks especially the PFF
they typically value accuracy a lot more
and underneath there's former
quarterback Twitter which is my former
partner and all your guys favorite homie
Chris Sims who ago I want bigger
stronger guys
then there was former GM's the Bill
Polian Zatch our little castle that go
on there and they talked to teams and
all that stuff the only part of this
whole universe that likes Daniel Jones
appears to be the NFL teams themselves
and if the anonymous scalp you know why
I'm out unbelieving in it but that's
what I mean it's I'm not seeing anybody
else
any other part of NFL Draft universe
very go and like I don't see anyone
standing furred for Daniel Jones which
is it's like we're all gonna be right or
wrong me really really wrong but like
look I'll just say I listen other
people's content and I was listening to
McShea talk to Kuiper and make Shay's
like look I am so out on Daniel Jones
that even though I even though I feel
like I want to be right on my mock and
he can go in the first round
I might not put him in the first round
because I don't believe in this at all
yeah and that's where hours are
different because we do things based on
what we're hearing what we think will
happen not what should happen
I have Daniel Jones 51 overall we're not
a man far I'll do it right now I mean
I'm I'm just not I'm just carrying out a
search of how we got to this point
because I've never seen a situation
where t nobody is no no I lied I had a
different joke like 69 I can remember
play nice I can remember players that I
didn't agree with going early
Eric flowers went 9 overall I had a
third round there were people that saw
the athleticism right I'm not seeing
anyone go and Daniel Jones is the guy
you know what people do with him and
this worked for Josh Allen because it
was true and there was traits doesn't
work for Daniel Jones
most team sucks he did lead the
we charted drops he did lead surely
n-c-double-a or he led the excuse me the
the quarterbacks in his draft he had the
most dropped pass if I told you that
there was a quarterback who his number
one traits was that his coach coached
the Mannings right Wiress drop ball hot
enough you'd say Oh is she have a good
personality right I would say aye
I actually liked Daniel Jones when we
thought he was a second-round pick and
now why I could buy somebody coming back
into like Lamar Jackson although I like
Lamar a lot better than daniel Jones
like Lamar Jackson somebody coming back
into the end of round one getting the
fifth-year option on it ray said we're
gonna work with him I'm not buying that
the Giants are taking him at six I we
can make all the Giants jokes in the
world no way no [ __ ] way
I do think teams are dumb though I mean
I agree but that's like Jake Locker went
eight overall you know I really the
story about Daniel Jones with the NFL
teams is he's killing the board like
coach coach look at his angle of the
marker I honestly clean a house Mudge
that he's good on the tape are on the
board I no doubt it has to be yeah and
he better be I like to say Ave there's
game he ran for like 186 yards because
he had to Oh against Carolina I was like
a second-round pick I really like early
in the season I was six football I would
talk him of all time like this yeah this
is my guy in the second round that could
be a starter but the hype trains gotten
sold I will be shocked aboard that we're
sitting there Thursday night and he's a
top 10 pick it should not happen to who
so much radio on the board right now
there's no one but give me your guess on
who do you think takes daniel Jones
the Bengals Zach Taylor Zach Taylor
wants his Jared golf can you imagine
taking in his although average athletic
quarterback that he's gonna have to make
to look good so it makes him look better
because he's I mean I thought good I'm
just I could just [ __ ] it I'll [ __ ] I
can see that one work having Andy Dalton
and then drafting daniel Jones is like
the twilight zone like it's like a sick
universe yeah it's like that one key and
peele with the continental breakfast
where he never leaves right that's
awesome
perfect scheme fit take a player that
you love
and put them on any team you want and it
doesn't have to be realistic I'm like
the mine was really mine was Dexter
Lawrence on the Chargers at 28 I just
thought that's exactly what they need to
be perfect
so take any of your favorite players and
even if they should have been even if
you love Devon white and you know he's
not gonna get out of the top ten but
there's a team where it would have been
[ __ ] perfect yeah where would that be
who wouldn't Quinton Williams and the
Patriots done yeah
perfect and it's the exact same defense
he could play knows he could play one he
could play three he played five like you
put him anywhere
he's gonna dominate bill would know
exactly how to get him in the right
matchup every week yeah but he could
just be I thought that way about Darwin
James last year was like please God in
some weird universe let Darwin James go
the Patriots and he almost made yeah I
have a couple I think TJ Hawkinson with
the Packers would be phenomenal
phenomenal until Rodgers didn't like him
any more possible shut the [ __ ] up why
oh no I'm just tired of a stick next the
whole I hate everyone I'm to like I just
I'm over it
what if what I've here at bleacher
report and don't don't get in trouble
what yeah hold on let me change this
yeah slow down what if I do you
understand any of why Aaron Rodgers can
be upset oh of course
okay yeah but I never feel neglected
yeah I feel like you weren't supported
yeah of course yes but if I were the
highest-paid draft analyst in the world
I would probably be okay you know what's
funny as eventually money doesn't matter
yeah that's how I yeah
like think about how many people in our
business left a big network to go
somewhere else and got paid a shitload
of money and we never [ __ ] heard of
them again and they got really [ __ ]
depressed there's a lot of those
[ __ ] Aaron Rodgers depressed
you think that's wrong with it I think
Aaron Rodgers is also realize where he
is
no offense Appleton Wisconsin but this
is a man of culture you know this is a
man I'm just saying that I see a lot of
the reasons why he's upset and if my
head coach was as much of a buffoon as
everyone's making him out to be right
now you know what I would have done them
not signed that contract extension and
said I want to go somewhere else I would
have pulled an Antonio Brown I said
trade my ass I'm depressed in Wisconsin
I have to date NASCAR drivers there's no
women around here get me the [ __ ] out of
tried 'fl for that well then that's his
problem
he was like where you're at if I didn't
like to look in some of you know I was
tired of the act like one he's there
McCarthy's not cheating oh honey
yeah and he got a hundred and some
dollars I just I just don't make that
Rogers one of his best years of his
career this year I want to see what they
put around him that's true because they
have two draft picks right offensive
lineman yeah past catcher so I mean I I
think he's one of those talented
Mitchell can ski because we're well
we're both tired of you talking [ __ ]
about it that's fine DK people are there
in Rogers people are tired of me talking
[ __ ] about everybody
what if TK Metcalfe goes to the Packers
chiefs they do Nathan I tanks now but
I've said any team that's what I'm
saying yeah
that one could actually have a decayed
of the Packers could happen I mean
electric electric stuff here it's just
out there soya just to go plays in the
dirt
yes football the whole thing yeah who
are their favorite play one of my
favorite players Johnny
Jonathan Abram guest in the show where's
the perfect fit for my favorite player
on their strokes yep
culture the best team for him him and
Malik hooker can just go hurt people's
seamless do if hooker could just be
healthy yeah yeah okay I want to I want
to talk to you off air about why you
like Aaron Rodgers so much because I
find Aaron Rodgers to be insanely
talented and I find that often we're
into honor
repairs and I think his offensive
coordinators the last few years have
been such a smack in the face that
they've given him Joe Philbin and Darren
bevel and Ben McAdoo and we see how
these guys do elsewhere and they've
gotten rid of all the talent and they've
given him wide receivers that were draft
in the fourth and fifth round and they
did go out and get Jimmy Graham
then they see the town and Aaron Jones
and they don't play them I just think
that I also feel a lot like sentiment
for him when people dig into his
personal life with his family and all
that [ __ ] and
use that as an example of how he's a bad
teammate and I just I I think a lot of
its [ __ ] and I think that he's
carried that team for six to seven years
just like Russell Wilson did where they
were winning ten games but without him
there winning four and I felt like he
just gets [ __ ] on a lot and I love him I
just wonder why are you that did that
resonate with you at all no okay
didn't it was well-spoken Thanks I mean
I love you I just I think also perfect
ski fitted am I crazy for this
Garrett Bradbury to the Vikings no not
great yeah that's a I just feel like
they've been trying to get an offensive
women for every bit everywhere Hollywood
Brown to the Steelers is something on
draft night that I think we should all
be rooting for that Antonio Browns cuz
of the drums old team as that drama
would be super great rockiest into the
Steelers is one of my favorite ones like
a physical top don't one my mock draft
pick for Monday was that that's right
yeah I love that one
it was I listen to it it's good rock you
Stan you're right yeah I don't try to
think what other great mmm
like where is the perfect spot for
Dwayne Haskins I like the fit with the
Giants I really do you like him as
schirmer's offense I like everything I
like him with Sheppard and say Quan and
Ingram I think the lines getting better
I think he gets it if you really want
him to sit if you could put Kyle armory
on any team or Ridge the Cardinals
well what cliff is gonna be electric
okay I mean I would love to see what
makes it actually think Haskins best fit
you might in Shenzhen natty amazing
Kyler Murray on the Rose know how Debbie
[ __ ] mad but I imagine the stuff he
would have him do a problem catch some
passes to everybody be doing everything
yeah I said Haskins at Cincinnati I
don't have you heard could you guys were
Haskins to sense and lusting over Kyler
to LA but I don't know will you put hot
consider on the Packers oh I would love
that fit pockets it on the Patriots is
the real perfect scheme really it has
the Gronk replace that would be scary
there too yeah where's the best place
for us to get the most out of no offense
I think it's actually Green Bay or
Kansas City he would never never make it
there but that's an interesting
I think Pittsburgh's another good one
for them is it weird that I kind of like
fan on the Raiders - yeah no that's a
good Jared cook and yeah they're a lot
of that's what I mean the offense the
premium version worst-case scenario
who was a player that you have a man
crush on that you're worried could land
on a really bad team Michael Hardman I
don't even know because he's saying yeah
he's good he's very good he's T Y Hilton
ish he's got the gas and we've seen
vertical guys get drafted and it's like
warming to doing anything while they're
playing with a [ __ ] quarterback that
can't write on the field so I'm nervous
about - Josh Jacobs did you say Nikhil
Harris no man call me Cartman sorry no -
Josh Jacobs he's right back
three down running back I mean he I
think he's a lot like so who scares you
that could possibly draft him I'm
worried he'll get drafted by someone
like the the Colts or the Eagles where
he'll be a part of a rotation you wanna
I wanna be the guy oh right Oakland is
where it's really the best fit for him
who are your biggest man crushes in this
trip I don't really feel like I have any
this year I look at Connor because we
talk all this you like debo a lot I like
debo Samuel AJ Brown yeah I really like
agent where's debo and AJ gonna go I
think AJ close yeah
and top around - I'll call my shot D
bogus 36 the San Francisco mmm I think
AJ Brown could honestly go 32-degree and
pretend New England I could see that
being a really good fit for him I want
to do some prop bets with you guys okay
because one thing that I believe is
there is an opportunity to make a
shitload of money on this event this
year and going forward as gambling and
gaming is now fully woven into this
country
here's my reason why betting on football
sucks the ball bounces weird ways you
have no control it's an athletic event
this is about information and I don't
think people have realized how much
money can be made on the NFL Draft if
you have information also think about
this Vegas makes their lines based on
the mock drafts that you guys [ __ ]
put out yeah they're looking at kuiper
and McShea and that Miller and Khan
and roto world and PFF and they're
accumulating all that to fit they're not
calling coaches they're looking at
public perception and making lines so I
think it's important to look at this for
our listeners and maybe there's an
opportunity to make some [ __ ] money
here let's do this you guys study this
all year round
so let's I have five prop bets okay and
then I'm gonna keep track of these and
we'll see how we do because then next
year I want a [ __ ] medal I was gonna
ask you megha so we have like a
sponsored betting website users okay
please I can bet on in Missouri can I
bet I don't know we'll get you out there
don't worry well well what we'll have to
do next year is I meant like tonight
money do have the draft show next year
in Vegas well then let's just ticket it
oh yeah all right first one quarterbacks
in round one over three three and a half
is the line over you have to bet 452 in
a hundred under you bet a hundred you
make 275 I'm explaining the lines for
people that don't understand what Plus
275 means I would go over all because I
think it's definitely for definitely
four yeah maybe five and you see it
being so you see it really being Kyler
Haskins Locke
Chanyeol Jones and then maybe someone
comes up for a Finley or somebody little
career or someone like that yeah I take
the over I do think Jen daniel Jones
will go in the first round it's just the
top 15 talk that's like what so let me
ask you the reverse of that question
you're looking at the players who are
the teams that you think are gonna draft
a quarterback in the first round Arizona
okay we know that the Giants you do
believe they will yeah okay I think the
Bengals will okay and I think the
Redskins will that's four yep so that's
where you see the over so you know
dolphins but you think it's gonna be
Washington Bengals Giants Arizona and
then maybe a burger or a Chargers or
somebody come traits back in yeah yeah
was any chance Pittsburgh takes a
quarterback I do I've been here I don't
know he's heard the same corner yeah
corner yeah so you're both going over so
we have to bet four or 50 to win a
hundred I probably wouldn't make that
bet
first wide-receiver taken I want to hear
I'm not gonna give you the odds I want
to hear you guys first Marquis Brown
yeah Marquis Brown yeah who I think has
the third best odds I looked at this I
would put so much I think deep DK Prize
the best sock guys I think it's even
better than that cuz I only have three
written down I have to go back and check
that the slip but the ones that I have
right here is decays at minus 120 so
you'd have to bet 120 to win a hundred
Hollywood Brown that's it yeah plus 225
yeah I would put so you that means plus
225 means you bet a hundred you'd win
225 AJ Brown is at plus 700 I would put
like a grand on Hollywood Brown being
the first receiver draft really yeah
that I live in mo you if you want to do
the coin Butler is bet a hundred to an
eight Nikhil Harry has been a hundred to
win 1600 Paris Campbell's about 100 to
125 marques yeah Hollywood you you guys
feel really confident yeah I feel good
about it I mean of course somebody could
take DK but I would put my money on
Hollywood alright so if anybody goes out
there and bets on Hollywood Brown send
us the ticket if you get it right
hell yeah if you get it right welcome
sorry bro we didn't do do we get any of
the winnings no no no because if you get
some of the winnings that means you
should also give some if you lose I'm
good with that on that one I'm fine with
all right yeah why are you guys so
confident about that one he's just been
everywhere yes so long and now they're
always medical recheck really really
supplemented things get be an eagle well
I don't understand that well they're
gonna get rid of a goal or okay but we
have a lot of depth issues on our
offensive line Jason Peters is 35 I'll
be gone by then defensive line I think
is very shallow and where is the line
back I'm hoping you know what my secret
hope is my secret hope is that Howie
engineers a nice little trade and goes
up there and takes one of the Devon's I
just don't know what you guys could get
no other than a lot of future pick we
have we have two second-round picks this
year so maybe give up one of those and
maybe another pick in the future and the
first like if we gave up the 25th pick
in the second round and the 25th pick in
the first round to maybe
and then another future third to move up
into like the top 12 to get a Devon Bush
Jeb Bush I'd be an awesome Eagle
you'd be great but I like to your point
I think the o-line d-line and my macro
b-y-o-see we doesn't make sense for me
the Eagles because they love the tight
ends and so when you have got hurt and
hurts on the field and now you have to
Sean Jackson with Al Shean and Aguilar
and Mack Hollins and a running back I
just don't think it's the gentleman I
think they're trying win the Superbowl
that's just me all right so Hollywood
Brown am I the only one that's concerned
that he weighs 168 pounds
I was mentioned to Sean Jackson it's
like the same dude yeah but just Shaw
was a second-round pick that was cuz
character they're not size so I you're
not worried about the size and now I
mean for what he is he's compact I mean
he and he was banged up all over saying
he's not a really skinny [ __ ] I don't
think he's any small he's not skinny God
she got you got you all right I just
want to be the one that asks the
questions all right so next prop bet so
we're going Hollywood Brown let me write
this down
Hollywood and over thus far
Nick Bosa as a top to pick yes - 300 no
plus 200 yes okay so yes yes okay
Clemson players in round one oh I'm not
going to tell you I'm not gonna tell you
the number you count them out right now
and you tell me how many you think three
three yeah it'll be the three defensive
linemen not named all cuz i over unders
right three and a half the over-under is
actually two and a half oh I would go
over a lot of people thought Dexter
Lawrence wouldn't be around that's why
so you have Dexter Cleveland Ferrell and
Christian book is there anyone else that
could sneak in No
so that's really a Dexter Lawrence bet
yes that's exactly what it is and you
guys and that's minus 120 so that's
pretty good I like that and the last one
I have here is will the overall number
one pick well his first hug be his mom
at minus 200 or the field at plus one
he's gonna be Kyler Marie
I'm gonna take the field cuz like yes
dad really interesting maybe that's what
they're gonna be as dad that's why you
guys are so valuable yeah because you
know the relationships for GERD bets
like this so you think he's gonna
actually hug his dad his dad's like his
everything yeah yeah see that's valuable
and that's going at-bat
I once 150 that's the best that's the
toughest one I've heard yeah I would
take that on that I I'm gonna go with
mom
yeah it's just a mom thing I don't know
but you're right the relationship with
the dad is like yeah I were sitting
closest that's well that's what I'm
wondering who you see
but imagine he won't be in the middle of
them I think he's dad I'll be the one
sent by him because his dad like his guy
he's very ball let me do a few more of
these team ones
how many Alabama players in round one oh
I would have to count three three I feel
good about feel good about Quinton Jonah
and Josh Jacobs yeah me too no no Irv
Smith no Deonte Thompson the lines three
and a half now go under be honest so you
go under and under is the favorite at
minus 180 okay how many wide receivers
in round one
I've won I think one as well this lines
off this lines two and a half I'll go
under that's that's the easiest one
really I'd be really surprised if we
went over that one I think AJ Brown
could DK Metcalfe could that's why it's
at that line but the only one I feel
good about is Hollywood yeah so how many
running backs in round one one one Josh
Jacobs so under as - 550 and overs one
so they're expecting the push there so
you don't touch that one we already hit
quarterbacks player selected third
overall which is so interesting because
it could be the Jets but it could also
be a trait yeah who do you get your
money on do you want to hear the odds
sure Nick Bosa plus $1,000 Wayne Haskins
possibly plus 1200 because the true
queen Ian Williams plus 200 Josh Allen
plus 200 well I take I'm rolling what
I've been saying Clinton q for months
yeah Quinn and Williams at - alright
three three
and then right now Kyla Marie's at minus
500 for first overall huh I mean yeah
what are you gonna do there yeah avoid
man yeah this NFL Draft feels like there
are so many questions yeah it's a lot of
mystery around it I'm gonna say that I
texted this to you guys yesterday this
is the first year where I'm going to
draft with a different mindset I learned
a long time ago through watching people
on TV and watch glanced at the other
networks and see kind of what they do
and then come back to us cuz you're
gonna realize that we're [ __ ] better
and that's okay because I'm willing to
say it but a lot of hosts feel the need
to give their opinions and they love and
something like this an event like this
where it's all based on information I
find it really misleading and so I'm
going to this draft for the first time
with no opinions about any player other
than Daniel Jones that's the only one
Jonathan Abram and I love Jonathan Abram
that's a fan thing so I'm really going
to this trapped
going to be leaning on you guys for the
information but I'm gonna do our draft
with what are the team's thinking what
was their intention because while it's
easy to make fun of Steve time and and
Caldwell down there in Jacksonville
they're doing it for a reason so I've
done all of my prep on the teams and
I've really tried to not do a lot of
prep on the players because if
Jacksonville takes JaJuan Taylor I'm not
gonna pretend like I know he's gonna be
all Pro tackle in here I'm done with
this charade with the draft there are
some people that study it all year round
they're sitting in front of me the rest
of us have been reading mocks for the
last few months and have been putting on
a [ __ ] show that we know all of these
guys and I'm [ __ ] done with it I mean
I appreciate that yes because I'm done
with it but it's everybody I see it
everywhere I can listen to any podcast
and all these media organizations I
don't really like his splits and I don't
really like this and they mentioned how
much he weighs I'm out or yeah
on an NFL field in pre-season I like it
because I also think this is what
happens with our draft grades is we fall
in love with players and a guy gets a
player and we go that's a that's a a
plus player right there
I mean maybe we're still gonna grade the
picture no no we're doing the grades but
no but I'm saying the grades in terms of
I think there's a lot of unqualified
people creating pics that's a lot my big
thing and I don't want to do that
anymore I'm willing to admit and that's
okay I just think people are afraid to
say it in this industry so I'm gonna
lean on you guys if you're cool with
that Thursday night in flux rock yeah
I can't wait no Derek Barnett freaked
out this year that'll be good and that's
part of the reason there is is I read
all these opinions and then after a
while I go that's my opinion now it's
called klepto nisha which is what you're
avoiding you're avoiding klepto Niva
which is when you steal other people's
opinions or ideas and you don't even
realize you're doing it yeah and that's
where the amnesia comes in because
you're not aware of it yeah well
naturally and then I say rocky send to
the Steelers well that imagine that was
a perfect example any other bold
predictions that you want to make before
the draft no I don't think so I have a
mock draft my final seven right about
Thursday morning my final big board
drops Wednesday morning some people
listen to this open the PR app my top
400 player big board will be in there
Connor and I are about to bounce out of
here in air view a local tree at our six
football I've it's gonna be awesome
you hear that Wednesday morning as well
so that's kind of we got going on and
will be will be on the desk early draft
night so we'll have some last minute
rumor stick I always have fun shoot the
show with you guys yeah always even if
you [ __ ] talk [ __ ] about Aaron
Rodgers yeah you just don't like smart
quarterbacks that's what it is cuz I
hate Tom Brady do you really know I
loved RIT I'm like the biggest Tom Brady
fan in the world all right guys you guys
are the [ __ ] as always download stick to
football check it out for all the look
of the homies a 33% love you guys a lot
join us for the draft it's gonna be a
lot of fun we'll be Hollerin holla holla
holla holla at you later for Miller
see man thanks for having us on for
Conor Thank You welco
I am the lef koe man
[Music]